well president Trump has made what some
are saying maybe his first public
concession to North Korea canceling an
annual US military training exercise
with South Korea now North Korean leader
Kim jong-un strongly complained about
the exercise and had threatened to
cancel the summit with Trump planned for
June 12th and Singapore the question now
is whether Kim will see Trump's move is
a sign of good faith or as a sign of
weakness joining us now with reaction is
Michael malice is the author of the book
dear reader the unauthorized
autobiography of Kim jong-il thank you
very much for being here Michael thanks
Pete so that's the key question I mean
you you don't want it we had been
talking time time again about we don't
want to make concessions upfront right
but if is this the type of thing that
brings them to the table and makes a
deal more possible well they've been
already been brought to the table now
these war games are happening every year
since for decades I mean the fact that
they're complaining publicly and
abruptly is what is unfair it would be
as if I'd called you up on October 30th
and said why are you having a Halloween
party tomorrow for 30 years for 30 years
they have backdoor negotiations Mike
Pompeo America's head spy met secretly
kim jonghwan without public notification
about this so we do have back channels
so the fact that they're doing this
publicly is to humiliate humiliate us
but frankly it's a small price to pay if
they say we're giving up new testing and
you're giving up these kind of war
exercises that's fine so you think he's
talking more to his domestic audience I
mean to hit to his people saying we're
still in a strong now I think he's
talking to us and making us clear that
if I need to stamp my foot I'm going to
stamp my foot and don't forget just
because I'm playing nice I can also play
not so much how do we not get sucked
into that game that's the game he's been
playing they've been playing for decades
I just give a little get a little
ultimately we build our news because
President Trump has already explicitly
said repeatedly I have no problem
getting up and walking away from the
table so he comes in with expecting
nothing
we already got three hostages so as far
as I'm concerned that's already a huge
win what is the thing kim jeong-hoon
cares about the most maintaining his
hold on power at all costs so he's gonna
need that assurance he's not giving up a
thing unless he knows we're gonna back
him or trying to come back him because
he doesn't want to end up like Hussein
or Qaddafi or Qaddafi even worse that is
his biggest fear yes what do you put the
percentage likelihood of a successful
June 12th meeting that creates an actual
path to denuclearization that's
verifiable quite low because they need
they regard themselves as a hedgehog
with spines going in every direction and
they need those nooks to make sure that
the US imperialists as they call us
can't invade so they believe they
believe their propaganda there's like
they believe the Kim jong-un when he
golfs every time he gets a hole-in-one
on every hole no but they do believe
nukes aren't affected to turn against
invasion and they do factual and that's
and that's the leadership and the people
and they've been told that and it's the
truth
I mean we're it's much harder to invade
a country with nukes than a country with
you know slingshots that's bringing some
facts and knowledge Michael thank you
very much a pre she ate it great stuff